la crise et le choc à marseille après
l'action coup de poing de près de 300
supporteurs résultats des dégradations
des vols les joueurs et les salariés
présents dit avoir eu très peur trois
cents supporters en colère
samedi soir alors que l'olympique de
marseille doit jouer son match face au
stade rennais sur la pelouse du
vélodrome
près de 400 supporters remontés à bloc
décide de prendre d'assaut le centre
d'entraînement de l'om
[Musique]
en cause la mauvaise gestion du club par
son président jacques henri eyraud
depuis quelques semaines c'est vrai des
résultats ne sont pas au rendez vous
pétards fumigènes sont lancées à
l'encontre des forces de l'ordre au
total 25 interpellations et un match
reporté
alors faut-il 10 août les supporters
ultras peu débordé ce soir après deux
mois d'absence il fait son grand come
back
le supporter numéro 1 de marseille rené
malleville est avec nous et croyez moi
il est très remontée et rené malleville
tout le monde en a parlé ce week-end à
c'était en top tweets c'était le sujet
le plus commenté
que s'est il passé à marseille vous avez
vu le petit sujet il y a un instant je
voulais qu'on revoie ses supporters qui
se sont introduits samedi dans le centre
d'entraînement du club et aurait dégradé
les locaux
je propose de voir une combine des
débordements c'est ça qui a fait
énormément parler ce week end et 20h41
qui jamais le bus un moment
[Applaudissements]
alors lors l'origine de ces débordements
bien entendu le gillon le c1 ce serait
des résultats sportifs décevants du club
de marseille des relations tendues entre
les joueurs et la direction du club qui
serait plus que remise en cause
et puis même si les supporters ne
peuvent plus se rendre au stade
ils sont quand même tenu a laissé
plusieurs messages assez explicite aux
joueurs lors des dernières rencontres
vous nous faites honte vous est
dégueulasse et ensuite ya donc eu ces
manifestations ces incidents à la
commanderie
rené ce soir c'est vrai que tout le
monde en a parlé et ça a été un
déferlement sur les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup de gens s'en sont pris aux
supporters marseillais et c'est vrai que
ça a été tout le monde a dit que ça a
été une année 6 a même été condamnée par
le président du club monsieur ayrault
qu'est ce que vous dites ce soir alors
voilà faut mettre tout comme bart donné
bonne discussion
personnellement je peux vous dire que je
condamne ce qui s'est passé et tous les
marseillais connaît ce qui s'est passé
il faut pas dire ouais il y en a que
sinon tous les marchés censées et tous
les supporters de relais même moi le
premier on condamne ces violences et qui
ont eu lieu samedi
alors une fois c'est ça c'est ça que
j'ai dit ça que c'est crade et donc
merci après maintenant moi car tu es au
top à clarifier le second poteau 6 et et
aux voix la série nos rédacteurs gentil
m'appeler de ta part tu ma vie orné
aulas et affirme vouloir parce que
pendant paris ce qui s'est passé j'ai
dit oui tu sais pourquoi
et moi parce que depuis samedi jeanne
mesplé pour écouter les grands de
formation tout tous les discours sont à
charge et des supporters oui il y en a
pas qui a donné les raisons de ces
déferlements que je connais ce qu'on
peut les avoir
voilà alors il faut dire une chose c'est
que ils étaient 400 supporters j'ai
parlé avec des supporters qui était ce
jour là ça me dit il mon dit rooney n'a
rien compris nous l'été avec les
fumigènes
les pas garde comme riche en terreau
démission du pape aux deux ils courent
on a vu arriver car tout se méfier de
tout doré et se porte hélicoptères comme
on l'a suivi
voilà ce sont des éléments perturbateurs
qui se sommes intégrés à ses supporters
qui étaient là quand il faut d'habitude
il avait mis c'était merveilleux
il avait mis des pancartes dans tous les
pans de marseille dans toutes les rues
de vente et sur l'autoroute
partout il avait hésité devant la
commanderie et les fumiers riche et si
c'était ça s'est passé
miquel d'un coup ita liq à tous et mais
je vous tue le bordel d'accord et moi et
lui il m'a avoué le maire les make money
money money mine c'est vrai on décore
nous commander colin sueur [ __ ] le
bordel mais il faut comprendre ça m'est
égal
pourquoi il ya plusieurs raisons d'abord
vous allez dire que ça rien à voir mais
ça à voir vous allez voir quand ils se
parlent dans la fosse voile avait tu
vois et les pins carte commence à 4 qui
se parlent à la vie comme elle est
actuellement d'habitude dans les stades
les supporters il sonne dans les stades
il se défoule le stade c'est un exutoire
et qu'elle ça va pas ça gueule ça le
port 20/2 mais les liquides boules quiès
tellement sa gueule c'est un exutoire de
temps que le le le stade vélodrome c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire marseille
c'est le temple l'étape ce retour tout
le monde toutes origines j'avoue que
noir a fait front national au délà qui
saute pas n'est pas parce qu'ils te
lèves et tu écoutes pas si tu vois là on
est bien là avec les décisions
gouvernementales et je m'excuse de fait
intrusion la [ __ ] mais il faudrait un
message aussi sage aussi puisque cela il
faudrait quand même morceau one à mon
mieux tous les mets à qui j'ai décidé
aujourd'hui comme interne une sorte
devait décider aujourd'hui qu'on va
interdire au sein et si on vous dit sur
les interdisait de parler eux parce
qu'ils foutent le bordel monstre et il
ya des jeunes de dizin
neuf étapes à capuche à la télé ils te
raconte il ya 14 garde à vue des
majeures mais qu'est marqueur disait dès
19h
c'est déjà là moi je vais bien que
digital qui est majeure mais ce sont des
jeunes - et inciter chaque mois les
copains et les copines patel e coupé
mais la schizophrénie à 18 ans il faut
qu'ils soir la maison les anons playboy
il s'entend il a cette chance de kiso la
seule chance de kiso c'est l'om parce
que nous sommes à marseille
oui mais c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement encore plein de gens qui
disent sur les réseaux sociaux oui mais
est-ce que c'est une raison pour faire
sa gym verdalle tard à temps non non
j'ai dit non non je parle et qu'elles
pèseront de tout l'été des leds
aboutissent à alors quand celle-ci
pression parce que disons non
voilà ce n'est pas faire admettre que tu
réponds aux gens qui disent à l'om à
marseille c'est tout et qu'elle commence
et où sa masse et sa rhume comédien et
aider et des supporters de rome
il viendra qui tous les sens ça il nomme
que ça et ils n'ont plus on peut plus
aller au stade
ma patronne à la pire des choses c'est
le président 1 0 alors justement
j'aimerais qu'on voit le président de
l'om qui sait qui s'étendent pas là qui
a fait une déclaration qui a été assez
mal prise regarder lyon qui s'affrontent
ce soir il ya une vision de l'om qu'on
connaît qui a fait des grandes choses
qui a gagné des titres qui a connu des
grandes sucré mais de l'om du chaos de
l'om devint entraîneur en vingt ans de
l'om parfois des magouilles de l'om de
la chronique judiciaire de l'om des
affaires alors bon là il parle à des
magouilles et puis il a dit voilà il a
reconnu ses torts mais a tout de même
condamné les violences mongo s'accorder
vue via la justice sur les magouilles
des justes les magouilles il parlait de
quelle époque jeu
vous posez la question bernard tapie oui
donc je vous ai pris mon téléphone et
j'ai appelé héros donc le président de
l'om moi voilà quoi il m'a juré surtout
les dukes qui parlait pas de cette
époque là donc je lui lis mais de quelle
époque parlé et m'a dit mais tu sais les
transferts les pas les transferts chi
jacques ory pourquoi tu as besoin de
parler de cette époque crée ton histoire
aujourd'hui c'est quoi ton histoire la
tête de l'om sait rien créé là toute
l'histoire
arrête de parler des histoires des
autres crédits c'est pas ça j'arrive pas
à faire prolonger préféré pas faire
prolonger un joueur qui lui se propres
joueurs parce que tout le monde est en
train de le mettre au pilori thauvin
n'assure que j'adore floret sauf que le
garçon est né vers l'angleterre
ouais il à diviser son salaire par deux
pour revenir à l'om
serra la vérité elle est là c'est vrai
et que ça fait deux ans qu'ils demandent
à être prolongé sa super déroulera
aujourd'hui au lieu petit coup casse toi
t'es pas prolongé à tant d ça va ça fait
deux ans qu'ils demandaient prolongée et
je te dire je vais bien maîtrisé
je connais ce qu'ils demandent il
demandait à être à égal avec steve
mandanda
voilà il demandait le même salaire que
steve mandanda on va continuer là-dessus
on passe à la dernière partie prêter pmt
alors si héros parce qu'il n'a pas dit
que ça parce que ça sinon parce qu'il
n'a pas de couilles a basculé aux
réunionnais stéphane oui je parle de ton
père et tu parles de bernard tapie comme
ça c'est le boss
c'est là les jeunes bernard tapie au
dessus de tout le monde à noël même ton
au dessus des murs jaune canari mérici
s'est permis de dire alors il ya trop de
marseille et des gâteaux de marché hier
c'est l'habitude fuller bernard tapie il
a répondu
regardez il y la rage et sur ce qui
s'était passé des tables assourdi il
faudrait mentalement triste parce que
pour dire la vérité et supporters nous
même si ses lames l'om alors il de mou
en ce moment une frustration je suis
tous les supports
auteur de football puisque niveau plus
haut les stades et je crois que c'est le
moment où chaque partie quand ils ont
des différends doit se rapprocher
alors j'ai un joueur de l'om qui ravit
un ancien joueur de l'om qui réagit un
très bon voire domaine qui me dit ce
n'est pas seulement les défaites c'est
aussi le mépris de la direction envers
les supporters donnent sony ne respecte
ni les supporters ni histoire ni les
anciens fois le pauvre pape diouf
paix à son âme tapie et j'en passe
bernard tapie j'en passe
ils ne font absolument rien pour
protéger leurs joueurs mon pauvre rené
même s'il n'a pas toujours été tendre
avec moi aimer ces gens c'est
l'olympique de marseille force à vous
les copains et bien sûr je suis contre
la violence
on les aura les méchants relais alors
est d'ailleurs plein de gens sur twitter
aussi qui dit c'est ça deale sa chambre
à ça dit on excepté sur twitter chute il
passe sur twitter il ya plein de gens
qui lisent sur les réseaux sociaux
qu'ils disent oui rené on adore mais
c'est pas une raison pour excuser qui
s'est passé
mais non mais il faut des paquets maman
tu peux pas j'ai dit c'est pas une
raison de 10 km samedi dernier il faut
condamner mais il faut qu'il faut
poursuivre en justice saison là ils sont
ils sont en lien avec son garde à vue
sont poursuivis ils sont actuellement
déférées leno qui sont poursuivis
personne ne chez nous personne à
marseille ne cautionne ce qui s'est
passé et assurer seule personne
voilà j'ai bien sûr résolu par la
violence donc personne que la gestion du
président héros soit catastrophique tout
le monde est d'accord mais je trouve que
les propos de rené quand même laisse
place à une petite ambiguïté parce que
c'est je condamne mais il y avait quatre
personnes qui sont venues et tout le
monde a suivi non rené c'était une
manifestation violente organisée par
lequel s'est tu parle pas des supporters
bordelais connaît de la connais très
bien
vol dans la vie locale monopole de
marseille n'était qu'à celle de nature
même pas brillé tu encore te mêler de ce
qui te regardent pas faut juste un coup
de fil je tournerai je suis très
tranquille en 2008 et en 2010 les
associations de supporters des boulogne
boys cette association il ya une
dissolution le parisien il ya une
dissolution de plein d'associations de
supporters j'ose espérer rené ouais mais
s'il éprouvait de graves ayant marqué ou
et les conduire des morales mois fait
appareiller les rageux finir du racisme
le poulain de coteau tour est fini et la
dernière fois qu à paris a perdu 4 la
finale là le bordel qui a lui a pas ils
ont mis par ya la mer sérieuse je peux
terminer juste mafara désespéré rené que
si un jour il était prouvé que cette
manifestation gravissime a été voulu
encourager par les associations de
supporters marseillaise comme les
yankees ou les winners jose leader des
solutions
aujourd'hui c'est tu portes billets
qu'ils existent plus de pistes je fais
là vous êtes trompés car on comprend pas
alors ça a même été repris sur cnn les
débordements à marseille jusqu aux états
unis regardent certains supporters de
l'olympique de marseille sont absolument
furieux de ce qui se passe actuellement
ils ont décidé de protester samedi et
les images sont terribles a fait des
centaines de supporteurs se sont rendus
sur le terrain d'entraînement et ont
forcé l'entrée
beaucoup d'entre eux étaient armés de
feux d'artifices et certains en ont
lancé ce qui a provoqué des départs de
feu
la situation a forcé le club a annulé le
match contre rennes plus tard dans la
soirée
excuse moi au delà de ça au-delà du fait
de condamner regarde l'image que
marseille a dans le monde
voilà on a que deux images aujourd'hui
de marseille c'est une avec une étoile
ce que le reste ça existe plus et celle
ci mangueira aussi un dernier
il ira au effectivement mais tu peux pas
enfin on est tous outrée à marseille de
ce qui s'est passé parce qu'on peut pas
donner cette image là de nous c'est un
jeune homme pas comme ça on est alors
rené je t'en supplie je t'aime tu sais à
quel point je t'aime arrêt de t'exciter
comme un taré qui ce résident encore
dans l'aubrac de preuves pour un court
séjour 10 dans l'ombre lettre morte à
m'énerver je discutais de cuisine avec
schubert avec moi vous parlez lui de
s'occuper avec moi c'est vrai que par
des cuisines et toi occupent eux tendent
à les mener les enquêtes de loi n'a
[Musique]
jamais nommé rené tu dis n'importe quoi
des années à marseille n'était même pas
encore nés que j'étais au rez tribunes
du stade vélodrome
je pense que tu défends tu d'effets
rooney tu défendes est fatigué mais que
cette année je construis viens de le
dire mais le condamne pas ce que c'est
ça emmerde et par mer des classes
j'avais tout ce que tu as tout le
week-end tout ce que tu n'es pas à
mémoire sur toi alors je dis que je
compte d'harry les dalles tragédie nous
comme maintenant le bullet to mars est
économe et les violences voies oui à
pronostiquer que havas voilà à l'arrêt
mais après il ya toujours un maire
edouard jean gilles métier normal vers
bâle et stéphane gil tu connais rooney
mais bon tu chauffes mais non mais
[ __ ] regardez par quoi ils passent
après après va passer pour l'espèce de
vieilles hystérie parties à l'accord
je suis pas que je suis pas le respect
qu'il appelle mon il a droit des femmes
oui mais là il le show fille au fait on
sait tous comment faire partie rodé au
quart de tour
on le fait pour le reste ce n'est pas
cet avis un moment donné au dessin
passionné rené c'est une âme - rené je
vais vous dire j'ai un respect profond
pour le garçon parce que parce que s'il
n'y a pas d'aidés rhône et bien sûr
limpide de la rédac sortent pas tu te
reconnais cocotte toile
je veux juste te raconter des anecdotes
non je suis la raconterai pas mais non
ça de métro moins en avant donc et c'est
pas grave prenez ces lames de l'om
réellement il est de temps en temps
comme tous les marseillais et déborde et
médias ceem aussi mais oui mais il faut
arrêter d'essayer de chauffer parce que
c'est facile à faire démarrer mais de
l'essence dedans et par là j'ai un jeu
serge july jay leno show qui donne son
avion sillonne tous les téléspectateurs
qui n'ayant qu'il a raison ça fait
quatre ans qu'ils éviteraient plus dans
l'eau et dans l'ombre à la manifestation
c'est pas la jeunesse que tu as quelque
chose à ajouter
non mais voilà je suis content que ya
heureusement qu'il ya ces fameux tapis
parce que moi je m'engage met en garde
ce n'est pas que j'adore mais l'om en
dehors de ma famille c'est semafo lycée
j'adore cette ville marseille qui est
sulfureuse de peut-être mais mais y
arriver à cet om que tout le monde adore
je connais pas de marseille qui se veut
pas de m
même les mecs ils savent pas que les
fouilles du football les lendemains de
mackay filo filo réveillère il
s'intéresse plus à l'om lorenzetti même
ticket à marseille prenez un petit bleu
nuit et je défendrai tous vos et l'om et
je suis monté ici aujourd'hui pour g10
je remonte et vous savez pourquoi je tue
beauté parce que je savais que ici avec
tout restait que j'avais tout le monde
ici même pour toi c'est pas ça m'a
vraiment c'est moi j'oublie tout je mens
pas un coup dur après il ya des choses
beaucoup plus importantes
avec tout le respect que j'ai pour toi
loin d'ici mais je savais que personne
n'était au courant de rien jeudi j'ai
pas envie d'être sur mon canapé à
regarder avec hervé bien s'éroder